for many fashionistas the marquee at the
brandenburg gate is the emblem of berlin
fashion week with a steady stream of
designers and visitors coming and going
just a short walk away in the upscale
hotel de rome things are more relaxed
here at the vogue salon 10 designers and
fashion labels are presenting their
designs to a select audience from the
fashion world
the salon was set up for the first time
in the summer of 2011 by christiana arp
the editor-in-chief of vogue germany
it annoyed me to keep hearing that there
was no good fashion design in germany
i didn't want to agree
but i didn't want to keep preaching
our language is often visual so i
thought i'd create images that's the
basic idea of the vogue salon first and
foremost to create a meeting place
between designers and boutiques because
that's essential these young designers
have to be able to sell and to be able
to finance further collections
one of the buyers visiting the vogue
salon today is joseph polk owner of the
renowned berlin concept store the corner
he sells top class fashion by
international fashion labels such as
salon valentino or christian louboutin
the businessman always attends
christiana arp salon at the fashion week
it definitely simplifies things for us
particularly a business like ours which
purchases high class fashion
she has a great eye that saves us from
visiting lots of studios and looking at
lots of collections
because she's already gathered the best
of berlin creativity in this show
the vogue salon has already taken place
eight times at the hotel to rome
each one of the ten labels on show have
been hand-picked by cristiana arp
they will subsequently receive advice
and support over the course of four
seasons
the fashion has to be well tailored of
course but there are also other criteria
it has to touch me first of all
and it has to have something about it
where i can see that there's a strong
voice which might still be in need of
training
another criterion is that they dare to
say cristiana it's fine that you see
things like that as editor-in-chief of
vogue and that you give me advice but i
see things differently
great
they need that strength these young
people have to assert themselves
augustine
have managed that the berlin label is
showing its latest collection for autumn
winter 2015 not far from the vogue salon
the franco german design duo were vogue
salon proteges and their work is now
gaining international attention
i think it all started with you know us
being noticed by christina arbing being
part of the vox alone this is i think
where people started to consider our
work
a club
i think the important thing about the
vogue salon is that we got the vogue
stamp of approval
that creates a certain credibility
karen yesen is just embarking on her
career the 29 year old is making her
first appearance at the vogue salon with
her label bennu berlin this january
on the eve of the show she puts the
finishing touches to the designs in her
studio
caronyessen's fashion is made from used
jeans and old sofa leather
she's hoping to find the perfect
customer by a vogue salon
it makes
i want to appeal to the woman who is
conscious in two different ways
who's environmentally conscious but also
fashion conscious
and i think that's sometimes still
difficult with some of the other eco
labels that they don't bring these two
things together
berlin
is the first step into the world of
commerce karen yesen has two hours to
explain her concept to the buyers and
media representatives the young designer
is happy about the initial response
i have already got to know one or two
potential buyers who were very
interested
we'll talk about the details later
otherwise i'm still waiting to see what
happens because it's not over yet
arp's vogue salon is going down well
again this season her commitment to the
fashion industry is plain to see
the german fashion council has just been
set up an agency designed to raise the
profile of german fashion abroad with
christiana
as its patron